When it comes to the resurrection, I don't know anybody more qualified or
interesting to speak about the evidence than my friend J.
Warner Wallace. He's been a practicing cold case detective for over 25 years and
he's never lost a case. He has a fascinating way of examining the historical
evidence for the resurrection through the lens of forensic analysis.
I think you're going to enjoy this conversation.
So please join me as we step into J.
Warner Wallace's office to examine the resurrection.
Before we jump in and look at the evidence, tell me a little bit about your story.
You know, I was a son of cops. My dad was a cop before me, and I was very always
kind of... Cops are suspicious, right?
And sometimes they're kind of analytical.
They look at the evidence, and my dad was that kind of guy.
And I wasn't raised in a Christian environment.
And he was really pretty committed as an atheist, and he still is.
So for me, I was looking at the first time I actually seriously looked at
Christianity, i think i was about 35 wow my wife Susie was more interested in
christianity than i was she had been raised in a church environment and she kind of
felt like shouldn't we be raising our own kids in the church well i was willing to
go okay as an atheist and so i went to a church with her first time i've ever been
in an evangelical church for anything other than a wedding or a funeral and we're
sitting in this church and the pastor described jesus in a way that just clicked for
me. He described Jesus as the most intelligent man who ever lived.
And of course there's many other things too, but that's the thing that stuck out in
my mind. I remember that. And I thought, I'm interested in looking at this guy Jesus
to see how smart he is. And that's when I started to read through the words of Jesus
and buy a Bible. I actually still have it, the first Bible I ever bought.
And I started looking at it forensically because I was a detective and I was
looking at eyewitnesses and I knew when an eyewitness was lying to me and so I
thought let me just take a look at the Gospels and see if I saw those deception
indicators in the Gospels and as I got more and more involved I was more and more
convinced that these are real accurate reliable records of this
Jesus of Nazareth and that for me was an eye-opener because I always assumed they
were fiction. And what about the resurrection, which is clearly at the heart of the
Gospel story? Why did you focus on that?
If you think about what Paul says in 1 Corinthians, he says that if we've been lying
to you about the resurrection then everything is a lie, we have been false
witnesses, you have no hope in a future resurrection for yourself and everything we
said to you basically is untrue.
So I thought, hey, this is all going to be game in or game out based on if the
resurrection was true. It's like when a witness tells you or a suspect tells you
something and you know if what he just says is true, he's guilty.
Or you know if what he just says is true, he's got an alibi and he's not guilty.
This was one of those kinds of pieces of evidence.
That's how central the resurrection is to the Christian faith.
What about the actual evidence for the resurrection itself?
So let's start with this. You've examined dozens or probably hundreds of crime
scenes. So you know when somebody's dead or when they're not dead.
How do we actually know Jesus died the way the Gospels describe it, by crucifixion?
Yeah, that's always I think an important...
For me, I had a couple of ways of explaining the resurrection as an atheist, that
either they were wrong about him being dead, he just comes back from being badly
beaten and he passes out maybe, appears to be dead but he's not really dead, that
was one possibility. But as you read through the account you get little
pieces of hidden science that after you've worked homicides and assaults you begin
to say well i actually think this looks like my casework so for example um there's a
scene in the gospel of john where john describes the thieves on the cross with jesus
right okay but there's a piece of hidden science in that passage because it says
that the guard came and stabbed jesus in the side and blood and water came out of
his body and they saw the separation of blood and water.
And I thought, I recognize that.
Because there's an attribute that occurs when you suffer cardiac arrest.
It's called effusion. And either the water builds up around your heart or it builds
up in your lungs depending on your body placement.
You have to have that kind of shock, circulatory shock and cardiac arrest to get
that kind of effusion. And at coroners, I've been to autopsies where coroners will
actually show me what this looks like.
So I think in the end, that's a piece of hidden science because if they stabbed that
side of Jesus' body and they saw the separation of water, that's probably pleural
effusion from his lungs. But that means he'd have to be dead in order to show you
that kind of separation of water.
And John didn't know what he was describing. It was Luke who was the doctor.
Well, get this, John didn't know it and I don't even think that Luke knew it based
on what he knew back in the day.
Here's why I say that. If you read the earliest readers of Scripture, which are the
Church Fathers, like Origen and Tertullian, Jerome.
These people were writing about that scene in the Gospel of John and when they got
to the separation of blood and water they said it's got to be some kind of metaphor
or something, right? A spiritual kind of
It's got to be the water baptism it symbolizes.
It must symbolize something because it can't be water that came out of him.
Why in the world would water... Everyone in the first 500 years cannot understand
what the water is And I don't think John understood it either, unless John is so
clever that he writes in this. Right, of course.
He's going to put this little secret that no one's even going to understand
medically for a thousand years hoping that someday when they discover it, it makes
them look legitimate. So I had a problem with that.
When I first read that and did that investigation, I thought okay what I know as a
homicide detective, I'm pretty convinced that Jesus was dead.
So Jesus was dead by crucifixion.
How do we know the tomb was empty?
because you can't get a resurrection unless he's buried and then comes back.
As a detective, what convinced you the tomb was empty?
Well, I think this is just a very simple philosophical process.
If you work people who lie, they typically want to set up their lies so they can't
be discovered. The quickest way to dispel this statement or this claim about the
resurrection in the first century would have been pretty simple.
Here's what you do. You go back and you get the body of Jesus and you drag it
around. There you go. Here he is.
He didn't rise from the dead. Here's the body right here.
So that's why we have in the record of the Gospels this really concerted effort,
right? To make sure that the body is not stolen.
Because if the tomb is empty they're going to say something, you know, they're going
to say he rose from the dead. The earliest records we have from either friend or foe
point to an empty tomb. So I think that that's one reason why.
The other way, of course, you could knock this thing down in the first century is if
you could get the original eyewitnesses to recant.
So those are the two fastest ways to end the story of Christianity, if it's not
true, in the first century. And we know that they were never able to produce the
body of Jesus and end it that way.
So we have to account for the empty...
Listen, it doesn't mean that the resurrection is true.
We just know the tomb is empty. We have to account for the empty tomb somehow.
Okay, so Jesus is dead, the tomb is empty.
How do you know he actually appeared to people?
Because now is when it tends to get more supernatural.
Yeah, so we have our claims that are written very early.
One of the things we look at as detectives are four things related to eyewitnesses.
Were they really there to see what it is they said they saw?
Two, can they be corroborated in some way?
Three, have they changed their story over time?
And four, do they have a bias? I look at those four things all the time.
So the question with the accounts related to the resurrection is how early are these
accounts? Because you know you can lie about somebody if everyone who knew the truth
is already dead. okay so they're written at the time when people would know if
they're lying and if you look at for example the claims in 1st Corinthians where
Paul boldly says at a period of time between 53 and 57 AD very
early in history he boldly says that hey if you don't believe me there are 500
people who are still here who saw Jesus on the same day now either that's an
incredibly gutsy lie that he's hoping nobody will check or he's just telling the
truth and there are still 500 people, most of whom are still alive, you could ask
and they all saw Jesus rise from the dead on the same day.
That's a very early bold claim. As a detective do you think the resurrection could
pass in a court of law? Yeah I think here's why.
There's only one other way to explain this and that is an elaborate lie.
This is a conspiracy that's held by those who want to advance a cause called
Christianity and that's where I found myself at the very end of this investigation
and I thought okay, now I've got to think about, well, could this just be a
lie? It didn't hallucinate, it just made the whole thing up.
And it wasn't until I had worked conspiracies for a number of years that I realized
that doesn't get it done either.
So it turns out that there are five things you have to have to be successful in a
conspiracy. The smallest possible number of people, holding it for the shortest
possible time with excellent communication between co-conspirators.
So if I stop you and ask you what happened, your story will match his.
Also, you've got to have tight family-like relationships and finally no pressure.
It turns out that the 12, and it's more than the 12 because in Acts 1 there's a
whole upper room full of people and they pick Matthias from that room to replace
Judas and then Paul says there are 500.
So there's hundreds of people, already too many people to be successful in a
conspiracy who have to hold it for six decades, way too long to be successful with
no way to communicate back and forth if Thomas is in India getting tortured
tortured for what he says is true, he can't tell you what Matthew was saying in
North Africa or what Paul has been saying in Rome.
No way to communicate. That's the other problem.
Some brothers are in that group but Matthew is not related to anybody so their
relationships aren't close enough and finally too much pressure and no one knows
this better than you who have done definitive work on this.
There is no ancient tradition related to the disciples that says they ever recanted
their story. So that's the problem you have.
Now, I would always say it this way.
Is it possible that this is a lie?
I would say, well, yes, because anything is possible.
It's possible we're imagining this entire talk right now, but it's not reasonable.
Is it possible he wasn't dead? Yes, but it's not reasonable.
Is it possible the tomb wasn't empty?
Yes, but it's not reasonable. The only reasonable inference related to the evidence
is that Jesus, he rose from the dead just exactly as it's recorded in the
Gospels. And when I realized that it changed everything take us back to that point
where you first realized it was true and then understood what it meant for your life
so you know you do all this work and you discover that what the Gospels tell you
about Jesus is true and I remember going home at the end of one workday and
sitting with Susie and saying you know I think if you had to ask me do you believe
what the Gospels say, I would have to say no, yes.
But you know what I don't get? And I said to her, and neither of us were Christians,
I said, I don't get why Jesus would have to die on the cross that way.
I mean, I get that it happened now and I've kind of fact-checked all that and I'm
good with it, but I don't understand why
it had to be that way. I said, do you get it?
And she said, not really. So we were at this place where we just didn't know enough
yet. And I had focused so
sincerely on just the issues related to the Gospels, and is this true, without
thinking theologically. So here's how I put it now.
If you will investigate the Gospels fairly, as a detective might, you will end
up with belief that they are true.
That doesn't give you belief in them.
If you will start to investigate the New Testament for what it says, not about
Jesus, but what it says about you, you will take the step toward believing that.